it's to launch so now to start talking
about it a little bit
started I started building pandas about
six years ago it was six years ago April
so that you know I think about it like
every April it was like when I was 23 I
was really frustrated with our and
looking to build a better a better data
environment for myself and then work to
to make that a more relevant toolkit for
for the rest of the the Python community
and I know that so you know many of you
are our active pandas users and so
certainly appreciate all the all the
support and and using the library and
helping helping make it helping make it
better so I it's been a about almost two
years since I finished it but I I did
this book with with O'Reilly to to make
the Python data stack more especially
pandas and tools related to pandas and
doing business analytics to make those
tools more accessible to a broad
audience and certainly the book has been
a way more way more successful than I
ever expected I have at least I have
three translations at my home office and
I think it's being translated into more
languages and I just who knew that so
many people wanted to wanted to learn
about how to use these tools and I think
part of that is speaks to the strength
of the ecosystem in the libraries and
all of the projects that that make sort
of doing data in Python very attractive
and an important sort of modern modern
of business and research so I founded
this company datapad last year we are
we're building a visual analytics tool
which I will tell you some about and the
technology technology that's under the
hood talk just a little bit about about
the big picture of how I got from when I
went from building an open-source data
project to building a business
intelligence and analytics company so I
was very interested in expanding
improving tools in general and in
particular building tools that are
focused on making people more productive
and in getting just getting work done
and you know at the end of the day
that's what I was frustrated about when
I started building pandas was it was
taking me a long time to do stuff and so
I started building the library to make
myself more productive
more effective in my work and I've
continued that theme in all of my work
sort of looking at end user problems
like like what are the what are the
challenges what are people spending a
lot of time doing what are the kinds of
things that you wish you were spending
less time doing and you know really
freeing you know data scientists you
know business analysts to be able to
focus on the actual value add work the
reasons why they're there rather than
having to deal with some of the mundane
issues of dealing with dealing with data
pandas of course has been been very
successful at making you know day-to-day
data wrangling working with tabular data
you know pretty pretty easy to do I
deliberately built in a lot of
flexibility into the data structure so
they could be adapted to to working with
many different kinds of data the same
data frame object can be used to work
with multi-dimensional multi-dimensional
pivot tables and some of the some of the
flexibility also makes the library less
useful for hardcore data engineering and
every now and then I get an email from
somebody who's frustrated that pandas
isn't more like isn't more like a
database and I quick to remind them that
that was never that was never the intent
it was you know intended for medium for
working with medium sized data which was
actually part of many April Fool's Day
jokes
I think tableau published a thing it's
like it's not about big date anymore
it's like medium data is really where
it's at I happen to agree but I say that
every day and not just on April Fool's
Day of course people are using pandas
for all kinds of things they're you know
general data munging people are writing
ETL jobs you know which you heard about
in the last talk using using pandas but
it's being used for a lot of business
intelligence and business analytics so I
want to talk a little bit more about
what is that if you don't know what that
is and sort of you know how I got to
where I am now so business intelligence
is a pretty broad field and this is like
my paraphrased you know Wikipedia
definition it has to do everything
having to do with taking raw business
data and turning it into something that
you can use to run your business and
that
be making a decision about advertising
spending or you know who you know what
parts of the business need more
attention what parts of the business are
doing well what parts aren't doing well
there might be there might be prediction
or statistics involved forecasting any
number of things a lot of business
intelligence is glorified glorified
counting but it's you know it goes from
you know very simple counting of things
often counting a very big things to more
sophisticated predictive analytics that
is intended for helping the business
succeed so small data big data many
different scales of data fall into into
the bucket that that is in this day and
age called called business intelligence
you may have heard of heard of visual
analytics so I wanted to give a bit more
precise definition of what this is so
when people say visual analytics usually
they're talking about tools that enable
you to analyze data without a lot of
coding and that might be some kind of
you know drag-and-drop type interface or
may be you know a tabular interface
where you know you but you are able to
analyze the data by clicking or
interacting with the data directly in
some way many people you know I guess
the if you've ever used Microsoft Excel
and used the the pivot table builder
that's one example of a of a visual
visual analytics tool I'll be at one
that's quite simple as many successful
products in the space product called
tableau which has been around for about
ten years and went public last year has
been very very successful of course
there's a list of you know visual
analytics visual analytics products that
go down to the floor Spotfire which is
now owned by tip Co is another
successful tool that offers some things
that are a little different than a
little different than tableau another
thing I wanted to define just for
everyone's education there's a sort of a
new term in NBI called called data
discovery which is a subset of BI that's
focused on making making the data highly
interactive and explorable
and in particular enabling connecting
multiple data sources and being
will define insights that span across
span across multiple multiple sources
and I think that this this term was was
born out of a need to describe a new
class of tools that went outside of kind
of the old school static static
reporting from the from the 70s and 80s
70s and 80s and 90s when the prospect of
interactive data exploration just wasn't
possible because of you know the
architecture of systems and RAM and you
know compute the slowness of memory and
CPUs during those times so so the
typical way that you know for the
longest time the way that people did is
did business intelligence is they had
some form of data warehouse or databases
there's the concept of a data Mart which
is like a temporary or an intermediate
store for four views on a much larger
data warehouse or some way to provide
like sandbox access to to analysts
without them screwing up production data
typically they're there the data
warehouse the database has a has an SQL
interface so you enter at your interface
through it by writing queries on on
tabular data there are so-called online
analytical processing I don't know if I
got the acronym right but OLAP systems
which are oriented around building pre
aggregated views on on data warehouses
that can be sliced and diced very
quickly and it's through the building of
OLAP cubes that many business analysts
traditionally were able to do the sort
of quick data exploration and data
discovery work but there's it came with
caveats and of course having some way to
visualize and to build reports using the
results of these systems some of the
problems and you know I feel you know I
don't I'm not as much of a bi expert as
some of the people in the room but often
the traditional BI system there's
there's a long implementation cycle
involved you have to get a lot of it's
typically very IT lead the building of
the data warehouse the building of the
data cubes is something that
that the IT team is responsible for so
if you as an analyst you have a
bottleneck with other people in your
organization for structuring and
warehousing the data in a way that you
can access it and you can actually do
the do the data analysis and this
creates a lot of headache for for
analysts who are just trying to get
access to the data just trying to get
access to the data just trying to get
work done and of course implementation
cycles can be very long so it might be
that you ask for some data to be placed
in a certain way and made available to
you and you might get it in six months
or longer so and this is this creates a
bit of a bit of a conflict for you look
at you know how you know with with the
growth of cloud businesses and you know
really just if you're starting a company
right now like an e-commerce or consumer
web company ad tech company so I'm going
to business that does you know that uses
the uses cloud services and it's growing
very quickly maybe you know you're
building off a venture capital or off of
some in a bootstrap you know internet
business model you have to move really
fast you're making decisions on the
order of days or weeks and not not
months months or years so it's it's more
important than ever to to be able to
access all of data that you need you
need to use to make to make decisions
but unfortunately as people are
transferring responsibility for their
data to other products and services and
the interest of moving faster they're
buying services to solve problems rather
than say having all of their data and
all of their applications in-house and
this creates data silos like you have
data in Salesforce and in Google
Analytics and you run you run your
mailing list on MailChimp and you need
to be able to analyze like who's signing
up for you know to buy you know to buy
your product so you have this problem
again of like the data is out there it
can be analyzed but you have to do work
to gather it in many cases to be able to
to get any in any insights out of it so
so this is the core problem that we have
been thinking about and I think that
many of the people in the
Python data ecosystem honestly our our I
you know I won't generalize but but many
Python data engineers and data
scientists operate in this this sort of
data silo analytics however much of the
the Python code that we're writing is in
the service of munging data collecting
data from places integrating it with
with pandas or with numpy or with other
tools and doing either that sort of
business analytics data exploration
process in memory in Python you know or
in ipython notebooks or using other
tools you know other tools in the
ecosystem so so many like data
scientists and data engineers have
become the bottlenecks for for data
analysis within within growing companies
all over the world so so we've been
thinking about building so we've been
working on building a system that solves
some of these problems
the so the core things are accessing and
integrating data being able to quickly
do analysis on it especially ad hoc
analysis that you don't know what are
the views on the data that you're going
to be building before you start looking
at the data and the last part is
collaboration and being able to quickly
take data that you have and put it in
front of somebody else in a way that is
useful and that they can they can
analyze it themselves
turns out this is really hard so it
takes it takes a lot of work so we've
been we've been building a system that
that has a lot of components but at a
high level you have you know users
working working with a product they
connect to all of their data sources and
then we build a system that is able to
ingest all of that data from many
different products and services and then
provide tools to collaborate on that
data to integrate and refine it and to
do analytics and produce visualizations
and pivot tables and the kinds of things
that they would need to share to for
others to consume insights so this is a
lot of stuff to build obviously so I'm
going to talk about some of those core
problems and how how we're leveraging
tools and in the Python egos
and have built tools internally to solve
some of these problems so the I would
say that the you know if to two hard
problems the first is the front end
problem of building a productive and
useful and intuitive user interface and
secondly actually making the making the
data exploration process as fast as fast
as possible and in doing it in a way
that we can provide a service that isn't
prohibitively expensive so balancing all
those things has not has certainly not
not been easy so let me just jump into a
demo to give give you a little bit of a
more concrete view of of what's going on
in datapad land so this is an example of
a dashboard that we built and if you've
read my book you probably know this data
it's the all of the individual campaign
contributions from the 2012 presidential
election so I produced a set of a set of
visualizations I asked for the video of
this this talk to not be published for a
few weeks since we're very close to
launch and still having people sign
NDA's so I hope you know I hope you
don't mind so the things we're looking
at here I have these are weekly so
weekly aggregating this time series data
so weekly donations total donations by
candidates so just for the top two
candidates this bottom-left chart is a
histogram is a histogram by by donation
size and then the total donated within
each bucket so if you look at this long
bar over here is people who donated the
individual maximum in the in the
election which is $2,500 and then over
here you have donations from grassroots
donors people who donated between zero
and twenty five dollars you see there's
a big spike at a thousand dollars some
people just donated a thousand dollars
to a candidate then over here these are
the twenty most frequently occurring
states in the dataset and the amount
total amount donated with
those than those states and so something
that we might want to do here is look at
characteristics of people who donated
the individual maximum so I can on that
chart select and filter those large
donations and if I'm connected to the
Internet I think there's like a golden
rule the demos never work so let's see
here
okay so I we try that again just just
try that one more time okay so I select
and filter on the large donations and
you see that it splits and is now
heavily weighted toward toward
Republican donors during those time
periods and if I pan over to the small
donations and let that go then that
react AIT's all of the all of the charts
given the the selection on the small
donations and I could further break that
down let's see here I could just I could
look at the large donations and then
only look at California in New York and
if you select limit by if you look at
just liberal states the rich person
effect goes away a little bit but we
could do kind of ad hoc exploration
maybe filter by City and let's say we're
interested in the city of Portland and
then maybe occupations and let's say
select teachers and so you could see you
know here with the donations by you know
teachers in Portland maybe who donated
less than a thousand dollars and so this
is like not big data but it's five
million rows of data and being able to
very quickly sort of filter and we
aggregate this data arson bugs you know
takes a lot of engineering work so so
that's been fun so so one of the
solutions that we that we came up with
for for being able to do this kind of
quick quick exploration and also for you
to be able to quickly sort of filter and
Explorer explore the data regardless of
how where the data is coming from
because what you don't want to happen is
for you
a product like this that you have to go
and buy a new database to actually make
the product useful which is what's
happening in a lot of cases so that all
of our analytics are happening against
all the data is is materialized as a
view on the underlying data sources in a
in a columnar datastore and we're doing
all of the analytics inside our walls
using the same in-memory query processor
and we're doing all of the joins
integrations between data within it
within our walls so a little more
technical detail about you know what are
these queries I talked about queries
like what are what are those things so
if you look back at at this dashboard so
each of these charts is the result is is
the the visualization of the results of
a query and so in the top chart the
querying is includes candidate and time
but time aggregated at weekly frequency
this chart down here is a histogram so
the dimensions are donation amount but
Bend with been bins of with 25 and this
demand that's in the state the only
dimension is state and then for each of
them I'm competing a single metric
namely the sum of contributions so you
can generalize and think about you know
what I'll call it VI query as being a
list of a list of dimensions which are
how you group and how you group the data
for aggregation so if you're using
pandas this would be the stuff that you
pass into the group by function measures
are the things that you aggregate the
you know the aggregations that you
perform and so the numbers that you
produce that are you know computed for
each group and the data and additionally
there there are filters which is what
what subset of the data do you want to
include in the query and there's other
things that you have to think about if
you have a dimension that has a hundred
thousand or a million distinct values
you might want to limit your analysis to
the interesting portion of the data
which might only include the ten or
twenty most frequently occurring values
in the data set
so there's an additional complexity here
in building a user interface for doing
this kind of work is that you have to in
the user interface you have to establish
a way to build a query which just tells
it tells a database system how to
aggregate the data and then taking the
results of that of that aggregation how
to map that on to a onto a data
visualization so I'm gonna show you
something that is very is still very
very beta but so this is a pretty famous
data visualization the so-called
so-called diamonds data set so if you're
an R ggplot2 fan you will know this data
set but uh so this is this is a an
example of a visual in Atlantic's visual
analytics interface all of my which is
inside you know will be shipped and
datapad these are all of my fields and
the data whether there it shows the type
whether there a number or a category I
have no dates in this data set but I
could choose a category and if I drag
that category 2 to the X field in the
interface I can choose whether to
aggregate that category or to use it as
a dimension if I use it as a dimension
it chooses to a default metric which is
the number of rows for each distinct
value of of clarity but because I
dragged the category to X it infers that
the right default visualization is a
vertical bar chart with the categories
laid out on the x axis but if I select
horizontal bars as the chart type I get
a horizontal bar chart but now it's
moved the dimension to Y because now the
categories are laid out on the y axis
but I could choose another category and
Y and now get a grouped bar plot or drag
that category to X and get a stacked bar
plot or I could drag the category to
trellis and get subplots for each of the
distinct values of cut so what's going
on under the hood and if you've used
something like something like tableau or
another bi tool you've already probably
already familiar with this the style of
data analysis is that there's an
implicit mapping between the metrics
that you have here so I could change
this to be say average price it's like
that didn't work
what's the Golden Rule demos that they
never work so if I change the if I
change the metric here what's going out
to the to the back end system is this
list of dimensions and any any
additional information I could say limit
to the top for clarity's and the data
set and that updates now I have only the
four most frequently appearing clarity's
so this is building a query which is
going into a database system and then
that is being mapped onto a
visualization and it's highly informed
by the by the types of dimensions
involved so if I have a numbered
dimension and a category dimension I can
turn that into a box plot or a grid of
box plots so it takes a lot of the
drudgery out of doing very simple data
analysis but it can get a lot more
complex I was gonna do a coding demo but
I think I'm gonna run out of time so you
can't do all of this work in in Python
of course but takes a lot more makes a
lot more coding so I wanted to talk a
little bit in more technical detail
about what's going on under the hood
what tools are we using why did we build
a why did we build a our own query
processor which seemed kind of insane a
year ago but is seeming less insane
less insane now because it actually
works and it's always seems a little
crazy when you're building something and
people are saying why are you building
that and like well it's going to be
great once it's done and it's not you
know no one actually believes you until
it's done so we designed we
we designed an analytic system from the
ground up to serve the needs of this
needs of this application it was heavily
informed by experience building pandas
things about pandas that worked well
both from a features point of view the
ability to express complex complex data
aggregations and also because I had you
know I was a database programmer in my
past life and in finance did a mix of
Python and you know working on pandas
but also wrote you know prodigious
amounts of sequel and there are a lot of
things about sequel that make it not the
best for doing analytics but yet you
know we have kind of did you know
analysts across across the world doing
huge amounts of analytics in sequel
which was not really designed for doing
data analysis but more for for data
warehousing and and manipulating
manipulating tabular data so I'll talk a
little bit about this other parts of the
stack outside of the of the analytics
engine there's a distributed system that
does query routing and load balancing so
most of the time when you're using the
system all of your queries are going to
the same machine in AWS where it which
probably has a lot of your data already
in memory maybe some of that data is on
disk but it essentially has a hot cache
of the data that you're working with at
that particular point in time we're
we're dealing with communications
between client and server using using
WebSockets which is the same protocol
that the ipython notebook uses and I
think honestly the ipython notebook made
everybody a lot more comfortable with
WebSockets I know that personally like
going into building a web application
and especially one that's highly
interactive in low latency I would have
been much more afraid about doing so
without the ipython notebook which
established it as a safe thing a safe
thing to do there's G event on the
backend for you know concurrency and and
for managing the the WebSocket web
WebSocket connections we build a tabular
data store so it's not pandas but it's
it's very similar to to how pandas
stores data in memory but
format on disk many reasons why we build
a custom format I guess the biggest one
is that if anyone's familiar with call
in their data formats the park' format
was not quite mature enough for us to
implement a year ago as far as I know
right and outside of that it's just
getting data into the system building
data connectors to all of the all of the
services that people use so if you look
at if you look at the pandas codebase
and I don't know how much you've spent
reading the codebase it kind of breaks
down into you have the the data frame
and the data structures themselves that
you work with and that's like the eight
so there's the API layer it's like how
the code that you write and how you're
describing computation on data but if
you dig down beneath the surface of data
frame underneath series you'll see that
really there's you know there's that
there's a tabular so there's a table
data structure and if you look at how
group-by is implemented and how all the
analytics that the panda does are
implemented really there's there's just
a lot of kernels of counting things
categorizing things grouping things
filtering things everything kind of
falls into various buckets of simple
algorithms and and analytics current I
call them analytics kernels which are
assembled to produce a more complex you
know we group the data we filter it we
aggregate it and then we present it to
the user in a certain way so we kind of
rebuilt that from the ground up with the
badger system I've become more of a C
programmer since since working on it and
a lot of the code is now in a shared
library affectionately known as Lib
badger
and that forms that the heart of the
part of the query engine so if you use
data pad after we after we launch you
know you'll know whenever you're
interacting with the system that it's
sort of going directly into you know
piles of a fun C code that I've been you
know sort of working on with my team
over the last year so the front-end
stack we're big fans of angularjs I
don't know if anyone is an angular
programmer and the
in the crowd but really great for
building these types of responsive and
interactive applications think react
react jest didn't exist a year ago we
might have considered considered using
that if Facebook had open sourced it
open sourced it sooner using d3 for all
the visualizations but a lot of the
we've built our a lot of our own
visualizations just because needing to
have tight control over you know how the
data is represented in the backend how
it's represented in the front-end and
how we're rendering it for the for the
user and there is a sort of I guess I
call it pandas Jas because it turns out
that there's no good data frames for
JavaScript and so I think I'm just gonna
become the guy that like goes to a new
language and it's like well there's no
data frames yet so I'm just gonna I'm
just gonna build them now because I
don't know how to function without
without a data frame that held true with
JavaScript not having integers is it
turns out to be a big problem so nine
minutes left huh I really talked fast
so one of the things that I had wanted
to do and looks like maybe and I have
time for it
to sort of go through that and go
through that FEC dataset a little bit in
a little bit in pandas and reproduce
some of the a couple of the things that
I did inside the inside the visual data
pad interface so my memory of pan this
is atrophying so this is gonna be a lot
of fun so if we look at the donation did
the domain donation amount column in the
data set so we'll save that into the
amount variable make this a little
bigger so if you use pandas in your
day-to-day work you're probably familiar
with the with the cut and the cue cut
functions so cut let's see pandas cut
and if I pass amount
so if you recall the cut function I can
pass a number of bends and it will split
the split the data set into two that
number of bends in linear increments so
if I use pan to stock cut and say I want
100 bins I'm so close up against my
memory limit on this machine that I'm
going to close close some windows
I have no idea what happened
I might a chance fate by loading such a
large data set into into memory on this
on this machine I actually I'm gonna
open it up to questions and sort of skip
skip live coding in front of such a
large a large audience so I figure
there's plenty of things that the folks
in the audience would would like to ask
I would like to ask about whether it's
you know related to my current current
endeavors or anything related to pandas
or the PI data stack or you know sort of
my thoughts on life the universe and
everything thank you
so you've shown some graphics over there
are some nice plots but are you allowing
the user to actually with your system to
go into the data itself like people
think spreadsheets or with the same data
structures is it something that you plan
to do yeah so we do have the ability to
do to do pivot tables so you know in
this particular you know this is kind of
an old an old user interface but so you
know I can build build a pivot table and
say select you know I don't know 20 most
frequently occurring states broken down
by by candidate and maybe adding you
know total donations followed by you
know median donation sizes for those
groups so you can do pivot tables
essentially you know charts are one
visual representation of a pivot table
if you you know if you kind of think
about the world like that so the
features that we've that we've really
focused on have been have been sort of
dimension and metric based data
aggregation and then enabling you to
sort of either drive the analysis using
visualizations or pivot tables or just
kind of you know just interact with that
data and a number of different ways
there's also the ability to to edit the
data directly within the application
without writing any code which solves a
pretty big pain point that you need to
do relatively small transformations of
the data you need to remove you know
limit values to a certain range or
rename combined fine-grained categories
into coarser grained categories define
new variables you know essentially
something like Excel Excel formulas but
being able to do it in the inside this
interface and have it apply to the whole
to the whole dataset so what's up we're
a tiny company and you know just we have
not yet launched so there'll be a lot
more futures in that in that direction
if we want to use this product but we
have some like sensitive data like HIPAA
data how do we do
we're focused on a we're focused on a
cloud on a cloud offering right now I
guess was something we could talk about
and talk about after the after the talk
but at some point in the future we
intend to offered offer the application
to be to be run standalone I don't know
when I can't make any promises but right
now we're focused on having a service
that is very easy for for businesses to
pick up and start using without a lot of
administration costs are you able to
handle analytic functions like defining
a partition and looking at first and
last things within there in some cases
we have we have quantile quantile
binning and a number of sort of
analytics which can be things like count
distinct first last sort of like an
expanding set of functions kind of just
people ask us for things and then we
build them but part of part of building
a custom custom sort of data engine was
being able to quickly respond to user
requests like adding new kinds of kinds
of analytics I think some some companies
choose to build their system using
off-the-shelf technology and that places
constraints because that you're often
aren't able to customize customize the
sort of the you know open-source tool or
sort of other system that you're using
to do the do the data processing is
there a difference in the interface for
the data scientists or that's more
development this is the interface for
the end user of the dashboards you know
how tableau we have desktop version and
the web server so for us there's no
there's no distinction between desktop
and web it's like you can you know you
can use it on your iPad you can use it
in the browser it's it's you know the
same interface everywhere we are talking
about like a pro like a pro mode that
hat offers like a scripting interface
for
for data scientists or you know Python
or our programmers to be able to insert
in custom analytics but that's sort of
on the roadmap and I think we would need
more more data about what people need
before we build that we do plan to offer
an API to push and pull data so to use
the product as like a way to publish and
make data accessible to other people
especially if you're in a night Python
notebook you have a data frame you want
to start it and you want to like
immediately send you know put that data
in front of somebody else and for them
to get an email saying like here's a new
data set for you to play with and you
could use the product as a means to do
that you have the ability to mash up
different data sets or different sources
yeah so you can you can do you can join
you can join datasets inside the
application we'd like to provide more
help more assistance in doing that
rather than having to sit and figure out
which are the the keys to join the
datasets on but all of the all of the
joining and integration happens inside
the inside the application what ability
is there to process data in real time or
somewhat real-time is it's coming into
the servers or the databases right now
it's a it's a it's a poll it's a poll
model so you you define the view the you
know the view of interest and this
frequency that you want to update it and
it might be that you want to update it
once an hour or every five minutes or or
once a day we're really interested in
streaming data support and being able to
push for you as a developer to push data
into the system or to attach to a
real-time real-time API but it hasn't it
hasn't been a priority while we've been
sort of getting an MVP ready to ready to
ship yeah plan on making the
visualization types extendable at all
how do you mean extendable like a custom
d3 code or yeah something we've talked
about it the one thing that would make
it easier is if we if we published our
which I'm not sure if will do or not but
if we published our
sort of JavaScript data frame library
which would enable it essentially would
be easier to build custom visualizations
that understand those data structures in
which case it would it would expect a
you know pandas j/s data data table
object and it would make a d3
visualization you could drop that in to
data pad relatively easily
so something we're thinking about but
because the tool is not is designed for
business analysts who are not we're not
JavaScript programmers it hasn't been
it's not designed to be useful by them
so we haven't been prioritizing features
that are that require a lot of deep
programming skills
all righty well thanks everybody for
coming to the talk